Good morning, John. And good morning, Nerdfighters.
It's late yesterday night, I've been up working
on Your Pants. Me and my team have been working
all day, including things like integrating
Facebook with your pants. But we've been messing
around with a Facebook application for Your
Pants, leading to some fairly awesome Facebook
messages like "Are you sure you want to remove
'Your Pants?'" and "You have removed 'Your
Pants.'"
...Starting to sound like a really, really
bad text-based romance simulator.
Do you want to touch the boob? (presses keys
[Y, enter] on computer keyboard) You are touching
the boob.
So, in lieu of making a giant annotated video
with links to everything on this bookshelf,
I wanted to show you a few things so that
you could get up and close and personal and
stop asking so many questions about it.
That was given to me by people at DarkHorse
Comics, this was given to me by my dad, we
used to go see hockey games - the Orlando
Solar Bears!
This here was given to me by a nerdfighter,
and that, I bought after Episode I came out,
and they're having an epic duel, and of course,
Obi-Wan is kicking his butt, 'cause he's much
bigger, and more adorable.
And we got our Bobble-John, you gotta have
your Bobble-John, lots of Sandman comics here,
these are all my graphic novels. My Hunger
Games is currently loaned out.
Down here we got Terry Pratchett books, Mars
trilogy books, Neil Gaiman books, these are
all DFTBA CDs
This is a giraffe here, and there's a giraffe
all the way over here; they are not currently
making love, which is too bad for those giraffes.
Here we have Jet, of Cowboy Bebop, with his
Netgun, and then up here we have my picture
from, uh, from Hollywood Nights, Junior Cotillion.
And there's John Green there! A Pro Image
from his soccer days.
We got Vidcon and Leakycon programs, here
we got some corndog stuff that a nerdfighter
gave me. You gotta have a Yeti. Here is an
evil baby, with a duck head on it; it's an
evil baby Hitler.
Hellboy, just chillin' out, here's a Chevy
Volt, this is the Concept Chevy Volt, not
the, uh, production version, which is out
now, officially. Yoda, of course you gotta
have a Yoda. This is amazing, a knitted anglerfish
that a nerdfighter gave me, Mace Windu with
his purple lightsaber, among all of the X-Wing
books. Here's three penguins that a nerdfighter
made for me, and then along the side here,
we have a bunch of Gungans, battling each
other, uh, stuck to it with blue ticky-tack.
This is the original Scuzzy Kizoozle Curl,
still crunchy from having all of the corn
syrup in his fur. Han Solo, because I'm totally
into the originals as well, and moving down,
we have a narwhal spearing a seal.
Lastly, down here we have Jar-Jar Binks, and
he seems to have been in some kind of accident.
Broken, and bleeding, as if someone was not
a big fan of him when that movie first came
out.
But earlier I was talking about Your Pants.
That is really never gonna get old. On twitter,
if you were following me, you may have seen
that I asked for logos, potential logos for
Your Pants, and I got a bunch, a lot of them
were really really great; I'm showing you
some of those now. Some of them were not so
great, but the consensus in my heart, go out
to Vondell Swain's logo, especially because
it invites people to remake the sign of Your
Pants with your pants. As long as you have
a friend who can do it with you, which I,
I currently don't.
Luckily, I do have a clone, welcome clone,
yes, hi, how's it going? Ok, now all I have
to do is this, and then you do that, and we
make the YP!
I am pleased to announce to you, right now,
that we are opening Your Pants for business.
But only for the first 200 people to arrive
in Your Pants. It's a limited public release
of Your Pants. We're gonna be cutting it off
at 200 people, this is a limited- to make
sure that nothing crashes, or breaks. So please,
right now, go to Your Pants, and if you can,
sign up! And we will theoretically be opening
Your Pants up to all people very soon.
I'm very tired from modifying Your Pants,
and coding CSS, and hacking Your Pants. In
short, I've been doing lots of things to Your
Pants, all night long. So John, I'm going
to go to bed and sleep way in, and then edit
this video tomorrow. I will see you in Your
Pants shortly, and I will see you in this
little box on Monday.